あ最近作ったアイドルなどと聞いてください
してえええええええええ yeah 意味かいえーいえいえげっ挙行
hey dj えっの意味ゴーゴーレッツ子アイドルへ
みんなお酒は良くない店ではダメよみんなタバコは良くない
ニコチン中毒になっちゃうみんなきっとここ
この中で大人になりたくなってる55
みんなうどんは大好きどの詰まったなれよ
みんな辛いものを好きちょっとがまんしている
ケット本当はみんなケーキが食べたいっててる空を見上げればいい戦記だ
ハロ4
大変プーチ vs サイヤ人
目じゃない踏めず大北北俺つく
公開んフェロ員だけは絶対ダメ
江国恭子打つへ飛んで行けよ
俺たちの恭子55恭子誰か誰かこの世界恭子
止める日は近いオープニングをで今
パソコンでささっと作ったんだよ
そうやっぱいろんな意見だったん
オープニングいらないっていう人もいたけどオリジナリティっていうかあはじめ笹の
動画ダーってもらうためにはオープニングがつけようかなと思って
つけてみました
ではどうぞ
って感じのオープニングなんですけどどうですか
あの足長いネコあ
4個戦争のゲームの猫であの twitter で
変えてもらって
あとのおばけの僕は
このエンディングでお化け出てくるじゃないですかあれの
僕は晒しです
踊り支えてくださった人がいます
最近ちょっとバイずっとが忙しくてコンビニのバイトねー
あんまり
ちょっと長らく走っていうイメージがあると思うんですけど
そんなことないすごい人が止まらない中で
仕事をするっていう
なんかでもすごい人僕
すごいいい経験しと誘って思ってるんですよ
ちょっとすごい
境に行っても
いってんだ俺今日バイトだったらいい
あと代表に課題打差なん
それ大学に課題だして
たらもう zucca に帰れるんでん
ちょっとまた実家に帰りますねー
ああああああああ
ni